tributes from around the world are
coming in for the victims of Saturday's
deadly attack at a Pittsburgh synagogue
New York City's Empire State Building
was lit with a single orange halo to
raise awareness of gun violence the
Pittsburgh Steelers held a motive
silence before their game yesterday as a
city mourns religious leaders are
helping people find comfort at a time of
immense tragedy one of those local
leaders is rabbi
Alvin Birkin he is rabbi emeritus at the
Tree of Life synagogue where he led the
congregation for 23 years he spoke to be
on a yesterday in Pittsburgh beyond a
good morning again hey Gil good morning
to you we spoke to rabbi Birkin after
last night's prayer service he told us
how moved he was by that outpouring of
support from the thousands who gathered
to pay their respects and by the
solidarity from people of all faiths and
backgrounds
he said it's moments like that will be
key and helping those grieve move
forward
you've led your congregation in times of
grief and in times of happiness how do
you lead them when something like this
happens though there is no rulebook
there's no instruction manual it's just
unbelievable really literally I believe
so now it is your job to lead this
congregation and to answer the question
so many have of why you know I think
people know enough to know that there's
no answer to that question and I think
for the Jewish community when we suffer
tragedies like this so often times it's
we say no one understands us and what
we're going through the wonderful thing
is that we now know as a Jewish
community in Pittsburgh particularly we
are not alone we have the support of
politicians we have the support of
officials we have the support of the
rank-and-file there's no doubt an act of
horror like this is a real test of faith
for so many including I'm sure your
congregants what is your message to them
it's just hang in there and be strong
take one step at a time try not to do
with more than you can handle
and be together this is a day that will
live in infamy
we'll never be forgotten ever by anybody
in our in our community in our greater
community in the Jewish community and
the Jewish world I mean has
the largest anti-semitic incident to be
recorded in American history the next
couple of days they're going to be
massive numbers of funerals here and I
think when they see the outpouring of
the community people will realize
they're not alone and that's a big big
piece of this one of the other things
that struck rabbi Birkin about this
tragedy was the suspects criticism of
the Hebrew immigrant Aid Society also
known as highest the rabbi and I both
have a personal connection to that group
who brought his family to the u.s. in
the 1920s and it brought my parents in
me in 1980 I reached out to haya cesare
Kivus and got a copy of my original
travel records there you see a photo of
it right there I was just 18 months old
and my family left the Soviet Union and
as political refugees we needed help
resettling in the united states and he a
says the russians refer to it bought our
airline tickets you can see my name our
family's destination which was Galveston
Texas it helped many families like mine
and I remember my parents every month as
much money as they could maybe $20 a
month they would write checks to pay yes
back for bringing us here and hearing
the archivist tell me that she found our
records and she found my mom's name and
my dad's and mine I'm sorry I'm getting
emotional talking about this but it's
just such a personal story and it's
helped millions of people like my family
resettle millions of Jewish refugees it
began in an 1880s to focus on Jewish
refugees resettle around the world but
most recently it's expanded to helping
refugees of all backgrounds resettle and
this one hits close to home Nora
no but I think it's important that so
many people know what this organization
is and what it does I agree with you
beyond a-- and so interesting to hear
about your own family's history and also
to note the highest is actually one of
nine agencies that the contracts with
the state department to help refugees
acclimate here to the united states its
aidid immigrants with diverse
backgrounds
that's the welcoming arm of america that
what makes everybody want to come here
I'm really glad that I'm glad that
beyond a shared that story because you
can put a personal face on it yeah I
never apologize for getting emotional
about something that's so personal we
thank you thank God they were there for
you yeah that's right we will be right
back